good evening
members um and welcome um I like to
welcome you to this meeting of the audit
committee uh and I have to read out the
emergency evacuation announcement there
are no planned fire drills so if the
alarm activates please leave the
building in an orderly fashion via the
nearest fire exit use either the fire
exit through the main doors of the hall
or the exit in the store room adjacent
to the stage is over there on my left
the fire assembly points the island and
front of the main entrance to the
building please do not delay your
evacuation or collect belongings do not
return to the building until given
permission to do so by Council staff and
the meeting is being live
streamed and please switch off mobiles
or turn them to silent and please note
the toilet and handwashing Facilities
available on the
folo um there's no members of the public
to warn about filming so we got to worry
about
that um okay and we can move move
on uh oh yes we use microphones as you
know and um during the meeting we invite
you to speak speak clearly into the
microphone and tap the button to turn it
off and you stop speaking that's um
something you have to do uh now agenda
item one there's apologies for absence
and we've had apologies from counselor
Judy Gooding and counselor Arthur
Williams okay moving
on uh any non-members
attending
no any substitute members
attending uh now the next item is the
minutes of the meeting held on the 27th
of
September
2023 um are those minutes agreed
members thank
you um and the next item five is to
receive Declarations of Interest are
there any Declarations of
Interest no no right well item six is
now uh is the audit audit progress
report number two of 2023 24 to consider
the report of the audit and counter
fraud manager providing an update of
progress made against the annual audit
plan of 20232 24 an action taken by
service departments in implementing
audit
recommendations and I believe I got hand
over to Mike Porter thank
you thank you chair if I can ask members
to turn to page 6.6 of the agenda pack
so in terms of progress against the plan
um we report here that a further for
audit engagements have been completed
and the further one is at the draft
report stage um since going to print
that is now five audits completed that
draft one's now turned into a final
report and the draft report wasn't
relation to economic growth and that's
now been finalized so we've completed
five audits but for the purposes of
tonight's meeting we'll talk about the
four completed audits um in terms of
those four completed audits we completed
an audit of gdpr General data protection
regulations um an audit of Recruitment
and Retention um an audit and it
infrastructure that was completed by our
delivery partner elucd day and we're
undertaking a light touch review of
build control so that's a piece of
consultancy work we undertook
in terms of assurance op opinions um we
provided an adequate opinion for gdpr an
adequate opinion for Recruitment and
Retention and a limited Assurance rating
for it infrastructure so I'd like to
briefly talk about the ICT
infrastructure audit as it received a
limited Assurance from ourselves so if I
can direct members to
6.17 of the agenda
back I'll just give you a chance to fix
it
update
so if we look at the key findings in
relation to that that piece of work so
what we identified or elucidate um our
delivery partner there was no longterm
it strategy in place which links it
service development to longer term
objectives of the council and Serv as
area needs there was no annual it
service plan to ensure linkage of it
activity to business and service
objectives and the ICT risk register not
up to dat so what this means is
essentially there's no road map in terms
of the future of ICT and how it links to
the objectives of the council but what
we can report is that a project has been
initiated to to implement a joint ICT
service so basically plans are a foot
because of this the one team approach
now we've got a I suppose it's moving
forward in terms of what ICT will look
like across both councils going forward
so we re see quite good Assurance from
the it manager in terms where we will be
in the future so we're quite happy with
that response so if we can move now on
to basically performance of service
areas in implementing audit
recommendations provided a
appendix
for sorry sorry sorry are you moving
away from the it yeah could I ask sorry
for the chair could I ask a few
questions before we move away from that
so sorry I wasn't sure how you want to
deal with it questions that's I was
wondering if you want to advise how
you'd like to deal with it but I'll take
questions now if you like okay on that
particular um area um where we're
talking about the um data breaches um
vulnerability to cyber attacks um I
understand there's a plan you're talking
about a plan in the future and you know
that I accept that and that's good what
my main concern is what are we doing at
the moment to keep the council safe from
cyber tax because I just read a document
before I got here about what happened to
Anne Council and 12 million to try and
get the IT services you know the data
breaches resolved and get the
information back so what are we doing to
make sure that this best we can doesn't
happen to
us yeah I mean you can never be 100%
safe against cyber attacks because the
the criminals are always one step ahead
so you're always playing catchup and and
you can't you don't have crystal ball in
terms of what's coming up next but
obviously we apply security patches to
our Network so our Network also has
patches and updates to prevent um and
also we we are do identify mware so we
have like any computer you have
protection um applied to the network or
the system or laptop
so in terms we can only be as assur as
that we apply security patches we can
only protect ourselves as much as we can
do I mean you know they're always one
step ahead so you can't 100% guard
against that but we Ure the systems are
up to date as far as patches applied and
therefore we hope to protect um you know
our systems from any of 10 by the
council and and also the weakest link in
in anything in relation to cyber
security is members of
Staff that's that's the problem P sta of
the major problem is that that you know
you can get emails come through and and
if people click on those emails that
puts the council at risk so the biggest
threat to any organization is actually
staff um the systems in in the main are
protected and they're quite you know
they've got appropriate updates applied
so the systems are not quite not weak
they're quite strong so the weakest link
in always is is is staff and what we're
assured is the patches have been applied
to the system at regular
intervals so the long-term strategy is
something something you're working on at
the moment yeah the long-term strategy
is essentially a road map for the
organization in terms of where it wants
to be in terms of I and what systems it
wants in place and how that links to the
longer term objectives of the council
because now in this one team approach it
might be that some systems become
redundant because you don't need two
systems you can operate one system
across the board and there might be some
value for money exercises or or
efficiencies to be had from the one team
approach so I know this might sound
silly but I I feel quite alarmed when it
says there's no annual it service plan
the risk register is not up to date so
really what I'm probably saying is in
view of all the key findings the
concerns where are we with managing
those to protect ourselves not just
patches on this and you you see what I'm
my concern is is that understand that
we're working towards something but what
we doing to mitigate any issues at the
moment because that's not imp CL so are
you saying that apart from patches
and yeah I believe actually um Emma y
has got some information just like a bit
more reassurance about those key
findings yeah thank you chair and thank
you counselors um good evening everyone
um it's probably helpful for me to say
something here because um it sits within
my area of um responsibility as as
strategic director um so first councils
I'll just direct you to risk 18 on the
Strategic risk register which is
actually in your taxs for this evening
as well um that gives quite a good
summary actually of our acknowledgement
of cyber attacks as a risk to the
organization and then the
mitigations that we take to um tackle
that so whether that's system design
whether that's recovery methods or
whether that's staff training to as my
colleague alluded to um we know that one
of the vulnerab abilities for all
organizations is things like fishing
scams or um Rogue attachments on emails
that kind of thing so we do do regular
exercises and training for our staff
around that so um that gives you a
summary that this is very much a live
issue that we are managing on an ongoing
basis and we've got a range of
activities that we undertake to um
ensure that we we do keep ahead of that
but you know it is a challenge and it's
a challenge to all public sector um
organizations and all private sector
organizations because you know there
will always be very clever people out
there that can do um quite kind of um
scary things with technology that you
know are always always going to be ahead
but we do whatever we can to to protect
um the council and to protect the
council's data around that um and there
are um plans in place for it so there
are service plans in place and there are
um road maps in place for improvements
whether that's infrastructure
improvements or um software improvements
um but I think probably uh they just
haven't ticked the boxes that the audit
was looking for so what we just need to
do is we just need to go back to those
documents and make sure that they're
fulfilling all the requirements to get
that um higher Assurance level from the
audit process right okay could I just
ask you the council public service
network expired in May 22 what does that
mean in
terms yeah so I believe that that was
the kind of government secure network so
the pcsn um network was a system that
the government had to um allow secure
exchange of data files between local
authorities and central government and
that's being replaced by different
system sorry for not very technical
answer there
chair thank you um Council Carter so
what do you actually run on the system
do you run like a nton or VPN or
anything like
that um so we have a number of kind of
antivirus products we have um firewalls
so there are various different layers of
security that we use to protect our
system and again I'm not a technical
expert so I'm not going to try and um
attempt to tell you what what those are
in in any detail um but we have a a
number of different lines of defense
against that so we have products that we
use and then we have a really important
part which is the education and the
training so do you get warnings come up
if anything comes on yes F soorry just
really quick what do you do about
restoring them back up how how do we
store that if we did have a Cyber attack
we've got some separate cloud or
something going on that we can get back
the information we especially with rans
and software and all that thing
how do we manage that CH if you're happy
for me to to respond to that we do take
regular backups of the council's data
and they are stored in the cloud so
that's that's a secure way of being able
to kind of roll back to a point before
the system was attacked um as such so we
again we've got really strong uh
recovery systems in place and business
continuity Arrangements in place for it
as well yeah thank you thank you as
councilor Wilson oh sorry c m thank you
chair um can I just uh I'm going to
refer to page 6.22 and 6.23 please um it
talks about um having um a document
which will um State the ICT uh I'm
assuming long-term
strategy and talking about including how
the ICT risks are going to be detailed
in the risk register the the end date
for that is the 30th of June um um I'm
assuming this is updating rather than
creating a new document is it is my
first question and secondly can I ask
Mike please through the chair um are you
confident that this will be done by the
end of June because that's quite a long
time to pull a document together that
really should already be in
place I suppose I I can't give the
assurance that It Be by complete by 30
June I mean that's the date they gave us
so hopefully they are working towards
that date but as suppose in terms of
assurance that what that would come from
the likes of um the it manager and Emily
so basically when we agree these stes
the dates a date they suggest they can
make so they wouldn't give a date they
believe they can't can't make so I would
suggest the 30th of June is something
they can actually are working towards
and can can basically yeah implement it
by that date because we do ask them to
be honest in set dates don't don't set a
date that you can't achieve so that but
we do have that robust conversation so
if they're suggesting 30 June and it's
likely to be the 30th of
[Music]
June thank
you
oh um I'm happy to uh
yeah thanks chair just I just wanted to
come back so can can I just ask um Emily
I suppose what what document do we have
in place that that lays out our ICT
strategy because um I think that's quite
important well it's it's quite an
important document and um assuming there
is one where where would I find it
please
okay thank you chair so I I think that's
the um Crux of the recommendation is
that there isn't a singular document at
this moment in time that sets out the
strategy in one place so there are
probably all I know there are different
um documents that describe different
parts of the it infrastructure or
different parts of the software but it's
about pulling that together into a
single strategy document so um just
going back to your previous Point um I
don't think it is a case of starting
from scratch it's about pulling those
things together into a single coherent
document thank you councilor Wilson um
I've got a a bit of a question um when
anyone logs into our system through
Outlook um obviously we have got the the
aess too and the counselors have been
instructed how use
authenticator um because that's quite an
important thing I know it can be a
nuisance at times because it pops up
want to let you in because you need a
number from authenticator but it does
stop someone
outside having that option to get in um
perhaps even to pose as as a member of
the council or an officer or whatever if
they happen to be lined up with that um
the other thing on a on a pre meet it uh
talking to Tim Willis um El Lucid dat we
used to look at this entire problem
because they specialist company hasn't
been taken very seriously by the council
that's why they've used used elucidate
to do this this this exploratory
Research into this and and I understand
that we are recruiting a a joint service
manager yeah there joint service manager
will have the responsibility of this
overarching maintenance of of this plan
runs smoothly uh and that's been really
taken very seriously by by the
administration just to let you know
that's what's going on thank
you so uh I've got councelor Wilson is
next counc SHP oh councelor sharp sorry
thank you chair um I I just noticed that
um that in in respect of Staff
Recruitment and Retention there is a a
limited Assurance level assigned to the
recruitment process so so I'd like to
ask Mike um how those shortfalls are
being
addressed
John I would have to go away find out
the findings behind that to understand
that obviously I didn't undertake the
audit myself but I can come back to you
on that okay thank in terms terms of the
ter terms of the pro progress there
would be a number of recommendation
assigned that limited Assurance rating
as you can see there's one major five
moderate recommendations so what I would
be doing is looking at the
recommendations applied to that um and
then seeing what progress has been made
so it's it's understanding what the
recommendations were sitting behind that
and then those those recommendations
would are probably in appendix 4 so you
can ascertain from appendix 4 what
progress been made in terms of
addressing that assurance that limited
Assurance rating so I would direct you
to appendix will and the recommendation
made there but um in terms terms of what
what progress has made um I can come
back to you on
that thank you Mr
pter you don't wish to come back on okay
U next is councelor Mr Wilson please
thank you chair through you um Emily my
question really is have we got
sufficient resources to undertake this
work to get strategy and that in
place
thank you chair um yeah so just picking
up the point that was made um by the
chairman about the um joint uh corporate
manager for it so that person is now in
posts that's one of the one team posts
across brenwood and Rochford um so a
fundamental um part of of their role at
being new in post will be to look at
those it strategies across both councils
um aligning where possible keeping
separate where it suits to keep them
separate but obviously using that
efficiency of being able to um share
resources across the two councils and
being able to um kind of use that best
practice across both councils to support
each other's processes so um absolutely
the the team is resourced to to do that
piece of work um and we're really seeing
the benefits um across the IT team
actually of the the Strategic
partnership between the two
councils um well um are there any more
questions
no um this this report is actually for
noting is it
yeah um just to note the progress of the
report um do we take it as
noted yes I take it as noted thank
[Music]
you moving on um to item seven it's now
the risk manager man agement update uh
to consider report of the interim
director resources to provide a revised
insurance and risk management strategy
and an updated risk
register thank you Emily
y thank you um chairman I'm presenting
this report on behalf of uh Tim Willis
who's our interim director for resources
um so take no credit at all for the
report but happy to answer any questions
um the uh and risk management strategy
has been revised after a periodic review
so it's reviewed on a regular basis and
that's there that's here before you
tonight committee members for approval
um and then the second uh part of the
report and appendix B is the Strategic
risk register um which is updated on a
quarterly basis and you'll be used to
that coming um in front of you and
that's for you to note um as I said
chair happy to answer any questions
thank you are there any questions m
yeah I think the uh the risk register is
is comprehensive the process looks very
good but I'd like to focus on
specifically on the
insurance um just wondering whether
actually it's probably better to direct
this to Tim but if you can answer I'd be
very happy um it focuses on um this
report focuses on the four policies that
are affective
being property
motor um liability which is referred to
as casualty and uh engineering and
computer I'm not actually sure what
engineering and computer covers but
that's that's by the side
um what I really want to focus on though
is is the contingent risk and by that I
mean the the risk that
RDC is SU Ed by a claimant as a result
of a contractor's
negligence um so a good example of that
would be for example a Norse waste
vehicle causing an injury to a resident
and a claim is pursued against the
contractor but also co-joined
c as a
defendant and I think the ideal best
practice in that sense is that
when going out to contract
RDC ideally should obtain an Indemnity
from a
contractor um but indemnities are
fragile and they don't often
work um so you back that up by RDC being
named as a co-insured on the
contractor's
policy so my question really is I would
like to see a statement somewhere either
in this report court or in the controls
as to what the practice is and obviously
I recognize that RDC has its own
insurance for such liabilities which
would respond but that would take time
an expense and would be a claim against
rdc's record which actually would feed
into higher premium so the the ideal
best practice is a preferred position so
are you able to comment at all on
that Emily
yours this might be something we might
have to get back to thank you but you
you see the point I'm making yeah
absolutely um I I can comment in quite
generalized terms around contractual
arrangements so any contract that the
council enters into will include
Provisions around insurance requirements
and liability for claims so um I take
your point that we should look to have a
consistent approach to that across
contracts because it's probably dealt
with on a contract by contract basis um
and our strategy should probably um more
specifically State the council's
position towards that when we're
entering into to contracts so um I'll
I'll take that away I I I do understand
the point that you were making councelor
about where does the liability sit and
there are some contractual relationships
that the council has where an operator
is working on our behalf for example
where we retain the liability so I think
we'd have to um take that away in terms
of what would be the correct kind of
wording to put into to this sort of
document um but you know to give you
some reassurance it is covered with
within each of those contracts with the
suppliers there will be Clauses in there
to cover insurance and liability yeah I
would expect that it's just that um it
would be nice if if it was
watertight uh to protect um RDC in the
best fashion I I do have some
supplementary questions on this as well
which is that you know there are four
separate policies with four different
insurers is there not an insurance
underwriter out there that offers a
package that covers all of these things
which presumably will be cheaper and
secondly is there not a
scheme run nationally for local
authorities that
provides these sorts of insurances so
that RDC would benefit from a cheaper
cost presumably a cheaper cost because
of pulling their risk with other local
authorities thank
you hand over to Emily thank you chair
um again I'm I'm probably going to give
you um a slightly vague answer to that
question and it's probably best for me
to take it away um with regards to the
different providers of of the um
different types of
insurance um I can only assume that when
they've been reviewed on an annual basis
that has been the most costeffective way
of of dealing with the different types
of insurance that the council needs to
require I would be
surprised um but of course we you know
we can look at having multiple types of
insurance under one um a provider um it
may be that there sort of Legacy issues
where contracts have been um renewed for
insurance um in in different ways um but
we can certainly look at that
um as far as I'm aware there isn't any
kind of national scheme for um there
actually used to be many years ago
because I actually worked for a broker
that acquired a broker that was was was
the broker for the local authorities
okay yeah but that may well have um just
disappeared I my understanding is that
it's for each local authority to
um appoint their own insurers at at this
moment in time okay uh one final
supplementary question on this is that
has the insurance Arrangements ever been
subject to an external independent
AIT well we are internal audit we would
do a review of insurance arrangements as
to an external review I can't comment
but the internal audit function itself
it is subject to internal audit on a
cyclical basis so we would look at um
insurance I can't I I can't say when the
last audit the insurance section will
undertake it but yeah we do undertake
but that Mike um pardon me will be an
audit of the processes what I'm looking
what I'm thinking of really is an audit
to determine the adequacy of limits and
coverage and stuff like that it's
it's it's done on a regular basis within
industry and I just wonder whether it's
appropriate to do it for a local
authorities yeah I think it would be
appropriate I mean each Lo local
Authority sets its own limits in terms
of and each each local author prob got
different limits in terms of public
liability and indemnity um
yeah I I know that rochard is different
to Basin so it's based on the risk
attached to that local Authority and the
premium is paid so each Authority would
be different but whether the limits set
by Rocher are appropriate
um that would be subject probably to an
external provider who's got more more in
depth knowledge of what's appropriate as
opposed to myself I mean I ask the
question because I actually do this sort
of work myself but not in in terms of
local authorities in terms of all
companies and it's surprising what you
come across in terms of restrictions on
coverage and exclusions that have just
gone unnoticed that are really very
important so it doesn't actually cost a
lot of money uh to do something like
this and it might just be worth thinking
of defly yes okay thank you councelor sh
giv us something to think about I think
thank you
members are there any other
questions oh sorry councel Mrs Wilson
sorry chair my my question is um related
to what councelor sharpas just said how
will his suggestion get taken forward
because actually I think this is really
important thank you um TR Emy thank you
thank you chairman um I'll pick that up
with the director of resources um I
believe that the external Auditors do
require us to make a statement to
confirm that our assur that our
insurance levels are adequate and they
do kind of make sure that that's in
place but I think what we could
potentially um do with looking at here
chair is a um sort of a external
specialist doing a kind of review for us
and making any
recommendations um of any shortfalls
that we might have in place or
Provisions that are not cated for that
ought to be so um I'll pick that up with
with Tim and um we can take that that
forward as a
suggestion right thank you uh members
any other questions Council gson I've
got a couple I'm not sure if I've missed
the vote and we've moved on but it sort
of moved quite quickly from the um
internal audit progress report so on um
p page 6.7 going back to that um r one
it says ongoing service review means
this cannot be done um until such time
as one team approach has been
agreed G we've already moved on from
that you sort of jumped
on I wasn't sure whether we were going
to cover some of this or not um yeah
okay don't worry you could you could
those question email and ask the
question yeah thank you any other
question
before
we
consider noting the
report is this report
noted oh we got a recommendation oh
sorry yeah we have sorry you're right
there was right yeah um right the
recommendations are but the revised
insurance and risk management strategy
is
agreed and the commit notes the report
so on that
recommendation um do we have a
propos well I can propose it from the
chair yes and do we have a second and
Council Mr Wilson is seconding the
proposal members please indicate if they
are in
[Music]
favor any members against any
abstentions uh and the report is um
noted thank you um now we have a a bit
of a problem with the final item the
audit planning report in that
representative of eron young is not here
this evening and we knew that
um debie hand son couldn't make it and
Tim Willis did make inquiries if she was
sending someone in a place and as they
couldn't cover it it's been suggested
that we defer this to the next meeting
the reason is that like most other
Audits and most other local authorities
they are actually behind uh and Mike can
give a bit of
a an update on that for you um and
um then they would be here to actually
explain what the situation is and what
they're actually doing which is which is
the
problem what would I say in relation to
this this is basically setting out the
work for the audit of the accounts in
relation to 2122 they' already started
that work so basically it's
retrospectively going back to basically
say this is what we're going to do but
they're already actually started that
work and it's near completion so this is
basically something that should have
come to committee but it got overlooked
so they're now ticking that box in
effect bringing UD the audit plan is
setting out what they were proposing to
do in relation to 2122 accounts but that
works already in progress so in real in
reality in the start of it it's just
basically bringing to this committee
setting out um what they were going to
do um Council sh yeah thank you chair um
my my recommendation is we don't defer
it because I I can't see the value of
this report it's really just setting out
what ER and young are going to do and
how they do it and it's a very
impressive looking document it's
probably a copper plate document but it
doesn't say anything other than that so
I think the most important document for
us to review is actually their findings
which I think would due uh in November
22 so I think that's really the key
document for us to consider not this
particular document having said that I
did notice and um I hadn't um spotted
this before but according to young as at
the 30th of March 22 the pension scheme
had a deficit of 21.2
million um I hadn't um focused on that
at all before not sure whether I'd ever
seen that before um so I'd like to know
if you have um the figures um what that
represents as a
percentage of the shortfall as compared
to a fully funded
position and whether that has changed
whether it's got
worse and if that is the situation
accurately is there a
program in place to for RDC to fund that
gradually over time to restore a full
fully funded
position m can you shed some light on
it's not something can I can answer so I
would have to defer that to to Tim to
answer that question or in due course to
the external auditor
theirselves that's why we thought was
best if the internal auditor was here at
the next
meeting um that that was that's a
question really for RDC noton
young I
mean I think it's the question that Tim
if we put it to Tim Tim can answer that
question
okay outside of the
meeting we appreciate there will be
difficulties with this tonight because
of him Tim not being here and the
representative eron young but I mean
that that is a a serious we could we
could get a written written reply for
that could we not for you and for the
councilors well I think it should go to
everyone yeah that's that's what we
should do yeah that that's what we
really should do yes well that's um yeah
I'm I'm all for that thank you so
sorry
chair yeah there are other questions
that might need answering so would that
not be better not to defer it and bring
it back so that other questions can be
asked
otherwise well the problem we had is our
key people not here no not tonight not I
I feel it should be deferred as
suggested gives us time to get together
really because it's quite serious yeah
there's an um expenditure and revenue
mixed up on here so it'd be quite
interesting to be able to get some great
understanding if it was B to to for me
yeah thank
you
counselor
Lindon oh the roof is leaking oh that's
fun is
it okay uh well members um that's a
situation with the the audit planning
report um it's I just realized that it's
only in the last day or so we realized
that we were rather hoping to get
another representative here from ernston
young tonight and that has not happened
um so we can defer that but we can also
get a a a written reply and answers to
those questions about the pension
deficit particularly and other issues um
one other counselor did send a question
in which is not on the agenda tonight
but we have agreed that she can have a
written answer to that as well which is
counselor Shaw uh I will email her
tomorrow and just let her know she's
going to get a response for for her
question uh and that that will be all
ready and if she wishes to come in she
may turn up at the next
meeting thank you
members members I'd like a move a motion
to defer this item until the next
meeeting so so a member of eron young
can be in attendance and I'll also add
to that that you'll have enough time to
get a written reply about these issues
as well for the next meeting do I have a
second councilor Gadson
thank um members those in favor please
raise their
hands it unanimous it's unanimous thank
you
um and that brings us really to the
conclusion this evening unless someone
else has got another point Thank you at
10 past